you've been doing action movies for so
long and obviously you're an amazing
shape but it must be getting harder to
do the action roles you're interested in
branching out a little bit now you're
doing less action or some action some
other type of film I think you're
talking about just a kicking punch yeah
the way like you I can't steal I know a
lot of ten years but of course why why
Jackie why do you go out of your way to
put me down
i-i've worked I am you have no idea how
good I am in a fight okay you're talking
about John John John with the car roll
over roll over on the table you know you
can't do it right but John off no it's
tough now what kind of role would you
like to be doing that you wish you were
offered more of I willing to do anything
everything of course slow motion the
[ __ ] who popped in with a girl kissing
of good know nobody higher me no one
hires you for no wait you want to do
romance romantic movie romance romantic
anything yeah yeah I think you'd be very
good in a romantic role I don't know you
should be offered that role
- oh no what's that - like you - OH
No
Chucky why don't you lump me in with you
I am myself with two oh yeah we both
yeah okay I am just the right age to
play a young handsome leading man okay
right Andy yes yes no I know what you
mean III don't actually I don't think I
don't think you're too old I think you'd
be me it would be I'm like the clown
from it I shouldn't be in any movie but
you I think it would be a very good in a
romantic role thank you uh next month
another new movie comes off yeah
next month and you get to do some
romance in that movie no very serious
very serious yeah okay well that's good
for foreigner totally there's uh no no
comedy nothing right yeah even though
I'm walking like this yeah hey yeah yeah
it's the hood let's say you're going a
completely different way because you
want to branch out at this I like I want
to be a true actor just like just like
Robert De Niro and Dustin Hoffman yes
all kinds of things not just always rush
hour 1 2 or 3 4 or 5
no I heard that you're not a heat I mean
in Russia our films are hugely
successful but you're not the biggest
fan of those movie because on the set I
don't understand this beats the English
so fast I just okay let let's check to
say that is what name saying is what
then after I say yeah everybody laughing
I still don't understand was
I wonder I want to do so many actions
and no no no less action
I said no I want to do this no no enough
with enough time you have to go home
sleep hey Kour
I said no I want to work no no union
work union rules
yeah don't mess with those guys yeah
you